John Wick chapter 4 blasts its way into
theaters on March 24 2023 and the people
who have seen it say it's well a blast
though they also have a few minor
quibbles about the Assassin's latest
outing the next John Wick movie looms
ever closer and it looks like it's going
to be another hit for Keanu Reeves
titular assassin expectations for the
movie have been Sky High bolstered by a
set of trailers and teases that suggest
this latest outing may be the most
thrill-packed entry in the series yet
even Reeves himself has gone on record
to say that John Wick chapter 4 blows
away everything that's come before in
terms of its action sequences that's a
very high bar John Wick chapter four
this movie is crazy with such sky-high
expectations some may find themselves
worried that the flick isn't going to
live up to the hype after all it's a lot
of pressure to put on the fourth entry
in a blockbuster franchise all you have
to do is look at 2022's Thor love and
thunder to know that fourth entries
sometimes suffer from diminishing
returns but despite these concerns it
seems that nervous fans have nothing to
fear critics who attended early
pre-release screenings of John Wick
chapter 4 have a lot of good things to
say about the upcoming flick Cinema
Blends Eric Eisenberg tweeted that he
was pleased to find that despite John
Wick chapter 4 being the longest movie
in the franchise yet its extended run
time feels warranted it's an epic with
smart pacing that never lets the action
feel exhausting and the set pieces are
phenomenal
Fandango's Eric Davis was similarly
impressed by the film's level of quality
particularly in its action sequences
Davis tweeted this is definitely the
biggest and most badass John Wick movie
yet with a run time near three hours and
an ending everyone will be talking about
no one does Action like this it's on
another level part 4 simply rules
beyond the Stellar action sequences
critics have also heaped Praise on the
movie's cast which features a mix of
series veterans and newcomers to the
franchise critic met neglia of next best
picture wrote Keanu Reeves continues to
push his body to the Limit while Donnie
yend and hiroyuki Sonata add a real
gravitas to the most epic film of the
franchise yet but even with all those
positive reactions there are also a fair
few critics out there that feel the
movie falls short in some minor regards
total films Jordan Farley found the
film's action to be a little excessive
and a touch too over the top writing
moment-to-moment fight choreography is
as thrilling as ever but the set pieces
don't have enough variety to sustain
their jumbo size Wix Looney Tunes Pratt
Falls stretch credulity even in a world
this heightened
but it looks like we have ourselves a
foreign
others have griped a bit about the
film's length critic Sean mulvahill
mostly said good things but noted it
went on too long varieties Simon
Thompson called John Wick chapter 4
exhilarating as it is exhausting it
seems those hoping for a breezy action
flick may find the scope and scale of
the film overwhelming perhaps the most
intriguing critique of John Wick chapter
4 however has to do with the ending
based on early reactions it seems the
film goes in an unexpected direction as
it reaches its conclusion insiders
Kirsten Acuna predicted lots of
surprises in this one that's going to
deliver a divisive ending nonetheless a
fifth John Wick installment is confirmed
to be on the way so make of that warning
what you will
hello hello
[Music]